If you are not part of the elite,
the elite,
then whether you are being exploited or
whether you are irrelevant,
I don't like those options.
I would.
I would like to even increase smile,
but still there is a big difference
between exploitation and irrelevance.
When you're exploited,
you're still powerful.
You are powerful as long as it to be
exploited.
Parents in your rotation,
they need you.
I mean if you're exploited,
for example,
you can go on strike and they care about
it because they need you.
They need you to work in the factory,
have to serve in the army.
When you're irrelevant,
you are much less powerful,
irrelevant.
People can't go on strike.
I mean if they go on strike,
who cares?
Now you can't go on strike,
but you do need to organize now this and
this narrative that the glorification,
the narrative where the worker is
central because their worker is
necessary.
This narrative is constructed out of
politeness but mainly in order to
exploit the worker and whilst you may
have a personal sense of engagement of,
Hey,
I'm like that guy with a sheaf of wheat
ain't live grand.
You still are simply a resource now,
but again,
you are an important resource and have
purpose.
You saying on a spiritual level?
No,
no,
no.
I mean from the point of view of the of
the political and economic system,
you are important and the fact is they
do invest in you.
Even if you live in a place like Nazi
Germany,
as long as you're not a Jew or something
like that,
Hitler would invest in your health,
in your education,
would build sewage systems in,
in the slums because Hitler needs you
eventually to work in the factory and to
serve as a soldier in the Wehrmacht.
Otherwise,
Germany wants to be strong,
so even within fascism,
aside from the obvious things about
fascism that that needs to be rehashed
because they sound sort of evidently a
bomb.
Annabelle,
the positive thing about fascism,
the ID,
the idea about us human beings
functioning as a unit,
that is not a lie.
It's not an exploitation that's not
exploitative in,
in the same way as a capitalist system
exploits people by selling the
deception.
Oh,
you know,
why don't we work?
It would be good when really it's
entirely.
Your labor is a resource for us in
fascism.
Isn't there a sense that there is an
earnest belief that the included group
are valuable?
It's not insincere and you're not being
duped or product.
Hitler wasn't going those stupid blonde
blue eyes.
He means he means it.
It's sincere.
Oh,
that's a big question.
I mean,
it's,
when you look at the fact is it's really
a myth,
but certainly there is a domain,
the sincerity of fascism or the
sincerity of fascism,
of really caring about the individual
German housewife and her children are
just a means to mobilize population to
suit the needs of the powerful in the
end.
I mean,
you see it in fascism like in,
in,
in many other regimes.
And um,
and of course there are always the
excluded excluded ones.
Fascism in order to function.
Fascism always needs enemies.
And traitors.
My list of potential ideas,
again,
there is a lot of misunderstanding about
fascism,
which is I think one of the reasons you
see a real resurgence of certain fascist
tendencies to danger for.
One of the misunderstandings is that
there's a kind of romanticism for the
inclusive group and if you have enough,
this is just the opposite,
that I think that when we tried to and
after the Second World War we were,
it was a central theme in every
education system in the west,
uh,
to warn people about fascism.
But I think we,
we didn't do a good enough job because
we presented fascism as a kind of
monster and we vilified.
I mean,
we didn't explain what was attractive
about it.
And what was attractive about fascism is
that he told people,
you are,
if you belong to the group,
to the right group,
you are the most important thing in the
world.
You are the most beautiful thing in the
When people looked in the Fascist Mirror
in the 19 thirties,
if a German in and looked in the mirror,
he did not see a monster.
He sold the most beautiful thing in the
world.
This is why it was so attractive
comparable to the worker in the wheat
sheaf propaganda poster.
You have an identity that is meaningful
to your culture.
Your individual identity has value in
the collective identity,
whether that's your area and looking in
the mirror or your a communist,
toiling in the field or factory.
You have purpose.
You have meaning.
They seems to be a resource that's
important when organizing society or
system.
Yeah,
and and you know,
it,
it flatters people and people like to
hear that sort of a human resource,
isn't it?
I mean when we're looking at.
It's difficult,
isn't it,
when talking about extremist ideologies
such as fascism and communism as we've
experienced it because as you just said,
we extract,
we extract from.
We don't include what must be attractive
about it and there is nothing wrong with
people feeling purpose or valued in the
collective.
There is something wrong with people
persecute in an but.
But,
but because we made this,
we wanted to warn people about fascism.
We did it.
We didn't really explain what was
tempting about it.
Why do people go after it?
It's a bit like,
you know when,
when I read Harry Potter,
when I watched star wars or things like
that,
they always make the same mistake that
they depict the bed guys is just
terrible and ugly and repulsive and then
are left with the sense,
why would anybody follow voldemort?
Why would anybody follow Darth vader?
These guys,
they are ugly.
They are mean even to their own.
There are mean and cruel and then you
don't understand what is seductive about
the dark side and the thing is the dark
side is very seductive because for the
people in it,
it's very beautiful.
Again,
you look in the mirror,
you see the most beautiful thing in the
world.
This is something that you know,
traditional Christian art understood
much better than modern science fiction.
You mean that the devil would be
beautiful.
The devil is beautiful.
This is.
Otherwise,
who would it be tempted.
So now we have an intelligent oration
that grew up with the idea of fascism is
the ugliest thing in the world.
And then when,
when they start to adopt fascist ideas
and they look in the mirror,
what the CS,
not a monster,
what they see is something very
beautiful.
And then they reached the conclusion we
can't be fascist.
Yes,
yes,
I understand.
When you want people to be vegetarian,
it can't.
You can't say bacon tasted awful.
You have to go look.
Bacon's great where we just can't eat
it.
You okay?
And the same with drugs.
Look heroin,
a lot of fun,
but I'm sorry we can't take care of in
anymore.
It's off the agenda and what?
Those things are resourced by.
His pleasure,
pleasure,
power.
These energies are attractive or these
ideologies,
they move through our consciousness.
No,
they all have at some point interacted
with human consciousness.
They are an expression of our
consciousness.
They seem to be universal's.
There seem to be perennial themes that
are emerging.
We want to belong to the collective.
We want to feel valued.
We want to feel purposeful,
antithetical.
In fact,
the dystopia that you're describing
where a useful class will vein flight
and to an unmanageable degree,
isn't it?
Then when we're looking at the systems
that have failed and the systems they're
succeeding and what we have learned and
what we're beginning to understand,
it isn't our obligation to begin to
present alternative ideas that somehow
embrace these ideas of purpose,
a essence and where possible throw off
the imaginary shackles of the systems,
preexisting requirements I eat.
Your value is as a worker.
Every single one of us in this room
right now is here because of our value
as a worker.
You May,
Jenny,
every single person he is being paid to
be here,
right one way or another.
And like,
you know,
well you love your husband got your
husband's in the room,
but you've already made these come up
all the best buy beers.
So like,
you know,
but like none of us or like the most
important things in my life are not my
values as a man doing a podcast.
It,
my children,
my wife and all human beings know this,
that,
that love is something that can be
realized through work but need not be.
And often is it.